e aí
a recomprar o tempo e se fosse possível
esse uma nova loja abrisse e nela
pudéssemos comprar horas o quanto você
estaria disposto a abrir mão
e o quanto você estaria disposto a pagar
por mais tempo
em 24 horas e aquela sensação de que não
damos conta vivemos a glorificação do
estar ocupados não ter tempo muitas
vezes é status e parar às vezes
significa não ser tão bom assim
fracassar na verdade nós somos a
sociedade do cansaço
nós somos vítimas das nossas próprias
listas invencíveis ser bons pais bons
companheiros bons profissionais manter
uma casa em pé e ainda ser alguém
e às vezes falta ar e era exatamente
assim que eu me sentia 4 anos atrás
vivendo uma boa vida mas no piloto
automático muito longe da minha essência
e do meu grande sonho da minha essência
porque eu sempre fui do mundo sempre me
imaginei viajando por vários países
desde criança mesmo sem sair do lugar e
quando eu tiver possibilidade de
vivenciar outras culturas eu sempre
voltei uma nova versão de mim mesma com
novas idéias novas pessoas e desde lá eu
entendia que de alguma forma as viagens
principalmente a longo prazo nos
transformam e que mesmo voltando a gente
nunca para de viajar
oi e eu tava longe do meu sonho porque
não vai dessas idas e vindas eu fui
morar na austrália em 2006 e lá eu
conheci tive a sorte de conhecer o meu
marido ricardo pai hoje do gabriel e do
pedro e juntos viajando pelo país nos
encontramos uma família que
incrivelmente estava fazendo uma volta
ao mundo e aquela história nos inspirou
muito e de lá nasceu o nosso sonho
quando a gente tivesse a nossa família
completa a gente faria o mesmo
o fato é que a família já estava
completa eu já tinha voltado para o
brasil estava trabalhando na mesma
empresa há dez anos o gabriel tinha dois
anos o pedro tinha 4 meses e eu
terceirizando muitos momentos
importantes deles me sentindo sufocada
mas o que era normal e o meu sonho lá na
frente esperando talvez as
circunstâncias perfeitas de temperatura
e pressão para acontecer tava totalmente
acomodada na minha bolha e na minha zona
de conforto
é mas aí o meu pai me tirou desse lugar
meu pai sem foi meu herói um cara muito
especial um neurocirurgião que dedicou a
vida inteira dele a medicina e perdeu
muitos momentos importantes em família
em função da profissão ironicamente um
avc transformou a vida dele ele
paralisou a mão ele não pode mais operar
e muitos sonhos e muitas coisas que ele
tinha deixado para depois não se
realizarão
e foi aí que eu pensei o que que eu tava
fazendo da minha vida do meu sonho e eu
e ricardo juntos entendemos que ajuda
era muito curta para não dar a volta ao
mundo
bom e que o avc do meu pai na verdade
tinha transformado um sonho em um
objetivo recomprar o nosso tempo e viver
um sabático em família mas para isso a
gente precisava de um prazo e a gente
determinou antes do gabriel meu filho
mais velho entrar na primeira série
tinha uns três anos para nos
organizarmos e foi esses três anos que
eu digo que começou a nossa viagem
porque ele essas três anos eu aprendi
duas coisas muito importantes a primeira
delas a consumir menos eu me desfiz de
muitas coisas eu fiz escolhas e
renúncias muito importantes a gente
transformou a passivos em ativos e eu me
dei conta de uma coisa muito importante
de quanto a gente tava gastando com
recompensas caras do nosso dia a dia
para aguentar a nossa rotina e a segunda
coisa delas é que eu aprendi foi
eu aprendi foi acreditar muito mais no
meu instinto e muito menos do que as
pessoas falavam porque se eu fosse ouviu
que elas falassem eu jamais teria saído
do lugar
é por medo medo de o mundo ser muito
perigoso o quê que as crianças vão se
lembrar disso tudo vocês são loucos como
é que vai ser a carreira de vocês depois
bom
tô com um pouquinho de medo e um
pouquinho de coragem com duas malas de
23kg nós partimos no início de 2018 para
seguir o verão pelo mundo confesso para
vocês que no começo não foi fácil a
gente ainda tava no módulo turista
tentando tentando ir atrás de todas as
coisas que tinham para fazer um módulo
muito fechado e eu muitas vezes tentando
entender quem toda nossa equipe junto na
nossa jornada que era a minha família
mas a gente ainda tava sim se
estranhando e o gabi meu filho mais
velho traduziu muito bem isso no começo
ele traduziu pelo olhar a nossa
insegurança ele nas primeiras conexões
com as primeiras pessoas que falavam uma
língua diferente ele começou a olhar
para o chão
eu e o ricardo notou aí você falou gabi
tem que olhar para quem tá falando
contigo ele falou mas pai eu não entendo
o que ele fala daí ele primeiro você tem
que olhar porque é muito importante
significa que tu tem respeito pela
pessoa e segundo só assim olhando no
olho que tu vai conseguir entender mesmo
que leva um tempo
e assim foi de olhando no olho no olho
aos poucos de pracinha e pracinha que
era o nosso nossa brincadeira preferida
encontrar as pracinhas do mundo estando
puxados em cima de skate longas
distâncias onde a gente contava
histórias algumas dos lugares outras
totalmente inventadas em cima de
bicicletas em pranchas de surf dentro do
motor home sobre as estrelas e muitas
casas muitos aviões a gente foi
encontrando o nosso jeito de explorar o
mundo e esse nosso jeito de explorar o
mundo fez o gabriel e o pedro entenderem
exatamente os 14 países que a gente
passou as mais de 60 cidades as mais de
quatro diferentes línguas cinco que a
gente interagiu mas não pelo nome pelas
pessoas que a gente encontrou nesses
lugares
e foi o power da bahia que um
salva-vidas que nos falou sobre as marés
e as estrelas que os meninos adoravam
conversar com eles todas as noites foi a
tia da califórnia a o primeiro crush do
gabi que ele ela receber ele recebeu um
cachorrinho na despedida de pelúcia bob
que foi uns 15 elementos até chegar em
londres num numa entrada de trem e o
gabi perdeu o bob nos na estação e todo
mundo chorou foi o matheu n cola da
itália que a gente tava achando que tava
indo longe do mar estava parando no na
colina longe da onde a gente imaginava
que seria o nosso paraíso e fomos
recebidos por uma uma vila inteira onde
todos viraram nossos amigos da nona
fazia o pão com nutella e os meninos
jogavam futebol por 15 dias sem ser em
si
o e aprender a primeira palavra em
italiano máquina eles gritavam quando a
bola passar quando um carro passava e
todos todo mundo tinha que parar foi a
burger one lá de baile onde juntos a
gente passou por uma situação vulnerável
no terremoto onde os meninos gritavam e
mais um terremoto e nós ok mas eles nos
acolheram na casa deles ensinaram a
cerimônia de agradecimento daquela
cultura e o pedro ficou olhando aquilo e
todo dia ele ajudava abbud a montar as
oferendas e até hoje ele pega as
florzinhas no chão vamos agradecer
e foi a sassá da holanda que a gente
passou um dia no parque juntos e eles
perguntaram por que que não pegou o
instagram dela foi na austrália a
valentina o enzo na nova zelândia o cauê
e aluna no chile o menino do cabelo azul
eu queria mostrar às pessoas diferentes
no mundo para eles mas os meninos o gabi
o pedro entenderam que as pessoas são
muito parecidas apesar de não serem
iguais que basicamente as crianças
brincam e os adultos sonham e eu e
ricardo que procurávamos antes de sair
roteiros e lugares incríveis para
mostrar para eles
e eu descobri que os verdadeiros
paraísos na verdade são as pessoas foram
essas trocas sinceras os sorrisos
espontâneos as conversas intermináveis
que fizeram a nossa jornada inesquecível
eu voltar e continuar viajando um
desafio o gabi o pedro voltaram maiores
do que nunca eles com esses tantos dias
juntos vivendo 24 horas criaram uma
irmandade
é muito forte poderosa e eles voltaram
para o novo mundo deles a nova escola na
primeira semana de aula a gente é
chamado para professora da o feedback de
como como estava sendo e ela falou o
gabi me surpreendeu
oi e a gente já falou e ela falou ele
levantou a mãozinha depois de ter
explicado como seriam as regras as
combinações e disse prof você esqueceu o
mais importante olhar no olho por que
significa que a gente se importa um com
o outro
o que é a cultura não é o que a gente vê
a cultura na verdade é o que modifica o
jeito que a gente enxerga as coisas e
como voltar igual da escola do mundo
e na bagagem a melhor herança as
habilidades que eles provavelmente e nós
vamos usar muito para o futuro do
trabalho e para o futuro das relações
humanas as poderosas conexões e o
autoconhecimento e para nós o legado que
a gente deixou para eles de coragem eles
saibam no futuro que a gente foi e que
eles possam também escolher parar fazer
um outro caminho re-significar e se
auto-realizar não só em um mas talvez em
dois três é foi uma experiência incrível
eu e o ricardo imaginávamos que
estávamos entregando na verdade
o ou enriquecendo o currículo deles com
uma visão de mundo diferenciada mas foi
o gabi o pedro foi o tempo que eu passei
com eles
o que me reconstruiu eu aprendi com a
espontaneidade deles fazer novos amigos
você é mais cara de pau falar com
estranhos eu aprendi com a criatividade
deles onde a gente não podia levar muito
brinquedo então eles achavam graça em
qualquer coisa achar soluções e
aproveitar mais eu aprendi com a falta
de noção do medo deles tem mais coragem
e eu aprendi com a falta de noção do
tempo que eles tinham onde cada dia eram
dias só mais um dia a entender o
segundos que eu tinha perdido e olhar
exatamente para que ele ficar aconteciam
os abraços apertados os sorrisos os
olhares que vão ficar aqui comigo para
sempre como que eu poderia viver sentir
viver 10 anos em um que foi que
aconteceu com a gente se eu tivesse
fazendo olhando
tô indo para os mesmos lugares com as
mesmas pessoas
e existem muitos jeitos de viajar o
mundo existem muitos jeitos de sonhar de
criar uma nova experiência seja ela qual
for abrir um novo negócio saíram de você
está abre um novo emprego e para um novo
emprego se reinventar
é mas para ser de uma forma
transformadora autêntica é preciso tempo
a recomprar o tempo é uma grande
oportunidade de não se perder de vista
e sempre sempre que der viagem viagem ou
uma criança viagem como gabi e o pedro
viajar o mundo é
e quem é sentido eu tenho né cara é bom
e aí